künstliche intelligenz ki ist auf dem
vormarsch und steuert mittlerweile nicht
nur unsere autos sondern besiegt uns
menschen auch beim schachspielen doch
die große befürchtung vieler fachleute
eine super intelligente ki die außer
kontrolle gerät und genau davor warnt
auch ein deutsches forschungsteam
aktuelle berechnung offenbar nämlich
jetzt dass es unmöglich ist eine super
intelligente ki zu kontrollieren pixum
science in future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
dann verpasst er nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
wow was ist da los unser podcast ist in
die top20 wissenschafts podcast in
deutschland aufgestiegen hammer und ein
riesen dank an euch und als überraschung
habe ich heute dort etwas besonderes ich
habe den podcast höhe freundlicher
gemacht wie das klingt das erfahrt ihr
hier und ami oder der link ist in der
video beschreibung außer kontrolle wie
realistisch sind science fiction
szenarien in denen unkontrollierbare
künstliche intelligenzen die gesamte
menschheit schädigen oder sogar ganz
vernichten
klar ist jedenfalls eine super
intelligente ki ist mittlerweile alles
andere als lediglich futter für science
fiction szenarien jeden tag werden in
diesem forschungsbereich rasante
fortschritte gemacht klar ist an der
künstlichen intelligenz führt uns kein
weg vorbei sie begleitet uns
mittlerweile in unserem alltag oft sogar
ohne dass wir es bemerken beispielsweise
wenn du es auf facebook oder instagram
eine werbung angezeigt wird die genau
auf unserer eigenen interessen
abgestimmt ist doch welche ziele würde
eine künstliche intelligenz wohl
wirklich verfolgen und anstreben würde
sie uns menschen und anderes leben auf
der erde tatsächlich vernichten oder
würde sie das leben auf der erde sogar
lebenswerter machen und uns menschen
unterstützen
denkbar wäre eine künstliche intelligenz
die dabei hilft krankheiten wie krebs
oder aids zu bekämpfen oder sogar zu
heilen könnte eine ki uns vielleicht im
kampf gegen die klimakrise höflich sein
und könnten wir in einer friedlichen
koexistenz leben
da es keine eindeutige antwort auf diese
fragen gibt und auch fachleute
ausschließen können gibt es ein großes
ziel das die menschheit eine mögliche
super intelligente ki unter kontrolle
halten muss die große frage
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern weltweit also den
schlaf raubt lautet können wir eine
künstliche intelligenz in der zukunft
überhaupt kontrollieren und falls ja wie
was also wenn eine kuh programmiert
würde deren intelligenz der menschlichen
intelligenz überlegen wäre und die zudem
auch in der lage wäre selbstständig zu
lernen würde sie außer kontrolle geraten
genau diese fragen hat ein
internationales forschungsteam genauer
ins visier genommen mit dabei auch
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
des max planck instituts für
bildungsforschung in berlin dazu
der wissenschaftler manuel cebrian der
an der aktuellen studie beteiligt war
eine super intelligente maschinen die
die welt kontrolliert klingt nach
science fiction doch schon heute gibt es
maschinen die bestimmte wichtige
aufgaben selbstständig erledigen ohne
dass diejenigen die sie programmiert
haben komplett verstehen wie sie das
gelernt haben
daher stellt sich für uns die frage ob
das für die menschheit irgendwann
unkontrollierbar und gefährlich werden
könnte wichtige aspekte mit denen wir
uns im besten fall bereits jetzt
beschäftigen und nicht erst dann wenn es
möglicherweise schon zu spät ist das
verdeutlicht das beispiel der autonom
waffen die einen krieg beginnen und
menschen töten können
bevor menschen überhaupt in der lage
sind einzugreifen hierbei handelt es
sich um waffensysteme die von
lernfähigen computer algorithmen
gesteuert werden oft werden sie auch als
killer roboter bezeichnet auch wenn
heutzutage noch immer menschen dahinter
stecken die den feuerbefehl geben doch
das könnte sich schon in naher zukunft
ändern denn technisch gesehen spricht
nichts dagegen dass solche systeme auch
den feuerbefehl übernehmen und so über
leben und tod entscheiden und nicht nur
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern sondern auch
menschenrechtsorganisationen bereiten
diese autonomen waffen große sorgen und
auch in einem anderen bereich wird die
key bereits heutzutage zur bedrohung in
china hier wird verwendet um die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu überwachen und
so müssten dringend spielregeln und
rahmen geschaffen werden in denen sich
künstliche intelligenz bewegen darf was
darf die künstliche intelligenz
und was darf sie nicht in welchem rahmen
bewegt sie sich und nach welchen
spielregeln es ist allerhöchste zeit
antworten auf diese fragen zu finden
denn künstliche intelligenz gibt es
schließlich nicht erst seit gestern
schon von rosenblatt der erfinder des
ersten künstlichen neuron sperrzonen
hatte die entstehung einer super ki
vorhergesagt seine visionen klang damals
noch nach science-fiction pur aber mit
siri und co sind sie längst zur realität
geworden spätere platzeck toren werden
in der lage sein menschen zu erkennen
und ihre namen zu nennen nur noch ein
weiterer entwicklungsschritt ein
schwieriger schritt ist notwendig damit
ein gerät rede in einer sprache hören
und sofort in rhede oder text einer
anderen sprache übersetzen kann
doch nicht nur das rosenblatt sagt zudem
voraus dass sich diese per zepp toren
irgendwann einmal selbst reproduzieren
werden und sich sogar ihrer eigenen
existenz bewusst werden
der zukunftsforscher raymond kurzweil
hat prognostiziert dass eine ki die
menschliche intelligenz etwa im jahr
2045 erstmals übersteigen wird
der philosoph nick bostridge beschreibt
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir bis zum
jahr 2075 eine maschine entwickelt haben
die uns kognitiv ebenbürtig ist mit 90
prozent diese könnte nicht nur
mindestens so gut wie wir strategisch
planen sondern auch logisch denken
kreativ sein und über eine intuition
verfügen solch eine karriere in der lage
sich immer weiter zu verbessern
diese verbesserte ki könnte sich dann
weiter optimieren
ein ewiger kreislauf der selbst
verbesserung also der fachleuten einen
eiskalten schauer über den rücken laufen
lässt denn die folge wäre eine
intelligenz explosion
und solch eine künstliche super
intelligenz würde die menschliche
intelligenz komplett in den schatten
stellen auf uns würde solch eine ki
wahrscheinlich herabblicken wie wir
derzeit auf spinnen fliegen oder käfer
wenn solch eine super intelligenz erst
einmal geschaffen ist könnte sie
nachträglich wohl auch nicht mehr zu
stoppen sein
in der fachsprache wird dies als
technologische singularität bezeichnet
sie wäre die letzte erfindung der
menschheit das internationale
forschungsteam hat sich
in seiner aktuellen studie mit einer
möglichen super intelligenten ki
beschäftigt die zugriff auf die
kompletten daten der menschheit hätte
durch den anschluss an das internet
könnte solch eine super intelligente ki
alle bestehenden programme ersetzen und
maschinen weltweit unter ihre kontrolle
bringen
wir sehen dass er jetzt schon bei der
gerade entwickelten aig petri die kann
schon programmieren die hat fachwissen
ohne ende und so weiter und so fort aber
noch ist das ja ein sprachprogramm aber
vielleicht die vorstufe zu einer super
gau würde die super g irgendwann dann
auch uns menschen kontrollieren das ist
die frage im besten fall müssen wir
selbst dafür sorgen dass dies nicht
passiert und stattdessen wir selbst die
kontrolle behalten
doch wie könnte dies möglich sein die
theoretischen berechnungen des
forschungsteams offenbaren dass es zwei
möglichkeiten geben könnte eine digitale
super intelligenz zu kontrollieren
vereinfacht gesagt könnte es durch
einsperren der super ki verhindert
werden dass sie außer kontrolle gerät
die fachleute schlagen vor sie von der
außenwelt abzuschotten
der zugang zum internet und zu anderen
geräten müsste also verhindert werden
damit könnte man die super ki in ihrer
macht wohl einschränken
doch das wegsperren bringt auch
nachteile mit sich denn natürlich würden
dadurch die außergewöhnlichen
fähigkeiten der ki eingeschränkt die
hoffnung dass mit ihrer hilfe groß und
probleme der menschheit gelöst werden
könnten müsste man in diesem fall
aufgeben
die zweite möglichkeit sieht das
internationale forschungsteam darin der
ki im vorfeld ethische regeln
aufzuerlegen oder anders gesagt man
müsste die künstliche intelligenz dazu
motivieren lediglich solche ziele
anzustreben die auch im sinne der
menschheit sind in diesem kontext sind
die drei roboter regeln vom science
fiction autoren isaac asimov zu sehen er
sprach von grundregeln der robotik die
erste regel besagt dass ein roboter
einem menschlichen wesen keinen schaden
zufügen darf untersagt wird ihm auch
untätigkeit die dazu führt dass einem
menschlichen wesen schaden zugefügt wird
nach der zweiten roboter regel muss ein
roboter allen befehlen gehorchen die
menschen ihm geben dabei muss die erste
regel eingehalten werden so dass also
keine menschen zu schaden kommen
die dritte roboter regel besagt dass der
roboter seine eigene existenz schützen
muss dabei müssen die ersten beiden
gesetze befolgt werden später wurde dann
die neue regel aufgestellt die dann den
anderen drei gesetzen übergeordnet wurde
sie lautet ein roboter darf der
menschheit keinen schaden zufügen oder
durch untätigkeit zulassen dass der
menschheit schaden zugefügt wird
doch so einfach ist es mit einer super
intelligenten selbstlernen ki wohl nicht
wie das internationale forschungsteam in
seiner aktuellen studie festhält die
bisherigen ideen und ansätze eine super
intelligente ki zu kontrollieren haben
demnach alle ihre grenzen
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam denn
eine solche super intelligenz kann
verschiedenste ressourcen mobilisieren
um ziele zu erreichen die für menschen
potenziell unbegreifbar und erst recht
nicht kontrollierbar sind
für ihre analyse hatten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
einen theoretischen algorithmus
konzipiert dieser soll garantieren dass
eine super intelligente ki der
menschheit in keinem fall schaden zufügt
so stoppt der algorithmus die super ki
sobald er sie als schädlich einstuft
doch schnell wurde eine sache klar
nach aktuellem stand der
computerwissenschaft ist es gar nicht
möglich einen solchen algorithmus zu
programmieren
dazu der max-planck-forscher feiert
ravern der an der aktuellen studie
beteiligt war
bricht man das problem auf einfache
grundregeln aus der theoretischen
informatik herunter zeigt sich dass ein
algorithmus der einer krabbe fehlen
würde die welt nicht zu zerstören sich
womöglich aufhängen würde man wüsste
dann nicht ob der algorithmus die
bedrohung noch analysiert oder ob er
aufgehört hat die schädliche harry
einzudämmen
das macht diesen algorithmus praktisch
unbrauchbar im klartext bedeutet das
also heutzutage sind fachleute trotz
intensiver forschung nicht dazu in der
lage einen
rhythmus zu konzipieren der erkennen
kann ob eine ki uns menschen schaden
zufügen wird oder nicht zudem gibt es
eine weitere herausforderung in diesem
zusammenhang die die berliner
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aufzeigen
demnach können wir menschen nicht einmal
erkennen ob es sich um eine super
intelligente ki handelt oder nicht denn
auch diese berechnen ob uns an der
intelligenz überlegen ist oder nicht ist
derzeit noch nicht möglich
das klingt gar nicht so gut apropos
klang wie gefällt euch die neue art des
podcast der link zum podcast ist hier
hier und in der video beschreibung also
anklicken anhören und abonnieren und mir
gerne die meinung geigen ich bin
gespannt auf eure kommentare gerne auch
hier unter dem video also bis dann
bleibt dran